GILBERT STRANG: OK.
This is positive
definite matrix day.
Our application was the
second-order equation
with a symmetric matrix, S.
And we solved this equation.
Second derivative, plus
S times y, equals 0.
And you maybe remember
how we solved it.
We looked for an
exponential solution.
e to the I omega t,
times a vector x.
We substituted,
and we discovered
x had to be an eigenvector
of S, as usual.
And lambda, which was omega
squared, is the eigenvalue.
But I didn't stop to
point out that if we
want lambda to be
omega squared, we
need to know lambda
greater or equal to 0.
So that is the best
of the best matrices.
Symmetric and positive definite,
or positive semidefinite,
which means the eigenvalues
are not only real,
they're real for
symmetric matrices.
They're also positive.
Positive definite matrices--
automatically symmetric,
I'm only talking about
symmetric matrices--
and positive eigenvalues.
OK.
There it is.
Positive definite matrix.
All the eigenvalues
are positive.
Positive semidefinite.
That word semi allows
lambda equal 0.
The matrix could be singular,
but all the eigenvalues
have to be greater
or equal to 0.
And let me show you exactly
where those matrices come from.
Those matrices come
from A transpose A.
If I take any matrix A,
could be rectangular.
And A transpose
A will be square.
A transpose A will be symmetric.
And it will be at least
positive semidefinite.
Why is that?
This is the simple step
that is worth remembering.
What's special about A
transpose A x equal lambda x?
The good idea?
Multiply both sides
by x transpose.
Take the inner product
of both sides with x.
Then I have x transpose
times the left side,
is x transpose times
the right side.
I'm OK with equation 2.
When my S is A transpose
A, that's my S. OK.
But now I look at this.
That is A x in a
product with itself.
That's the length
of A x squared.
Any time I have y
transpose y, I'm
getting the length of y squared.
Here y is A x, so I'm getting
the length of A x squared.
Over here, y is
x, so I'm getting
the length of x squared.
And you see that number
lambda is, in this equation,
I have a number that
can't be negative.
A number that's
positive, for sure.
Because x is not the 0 vector.
So lambda is never negative.
A x could be the 0 vector.
If we were in a singular case,
In that case, I would only
learn lambda equals 0,
and I'd be in this
semidefinite case.
So if I want to move from
semidefinite to definite,
then I must rule out
A x equals 0 there.
Because that's
certainly a possibility.
If I took the 0
matrix, all 0's, as A,
A transpose A would
be the 0 matrix.
That would be symmetric.
All its eigenvalues would be 0.
Would it be positive
semidefinite?
Yes.
All its eigenvalues
would actually be 0.
Of course, that's not a
case that we are really
thinking about.
More often we're
in this good case
where all the
eigenvalues are above 0.
OK.
So that's the meaning.
And now the next job.
How do we recognize a
positive definite matrix?
It has to be symmetric.
That's easy to see.
But how can we tell if its
eigenvalues are positive?
That's not fun because computing
eigenvalues is a big job.
For a large matrix,
we take time on that.
We didn't know how to do
it a little while ago.
Now there are good
ways to do it,
but it's not for paper
and pencil, and not for I.
So how can we tell that all
the eigenvalues are positive?
Well, we only want
to know their sign.
We don't have to
know what they are.
We don't know that we need the
number, we just want to know
is it a positive number.
And there are
several neat tests.
Can I show you them?
I'm going to have five tests.
Five equivalent tests.
Any one of these tests is
sufficient to make the matrix S
positive definite.
There is a particular S there
that I'll use as a test matrix.
So there is a
symmetric matrix S.
And I know it is
positive definite.
But how do I know?
OK.
Well.
So can you take
five things here?
They connect all
of linear algebra.
It's really beautiful.
That the eigenvalues, that's
one chapter of linear algebra.
The pivots are another
chapter of linear algebra.
Do you remember about pivots?
That's when you do elimination.
So 4 is the first pivot.
The first pivot.
Pivot number 1 is the 4.
And then when I take a multiple
of that away from that,
I get a second pivot.
And I'd see that
that was positive.
So what's that?
Maybe I take 1 and
1/2 away of this.
I multiply that by
1 and 1/2, 6, 9.
Subtract from 6, 10.
So I actually get
a 1 down there.
So pivot number 2
is a 1 in that case.
Right?
6, 9 taken away from
6, 10 leaves me 0, 1.
OK.
It passed the pivot test.
Notice I didn't compute
the eigenvalues.
I'm just doing other tests.
Now here's another
beautiful test.
It involves determinants.
Now, I have to say upper.
Upper left.
Upper left determinants
greater than 0.
What do I mean by an
upper left determinant?
I look at my matrix.
That's a 1 by 1 determinant.
Certainly positive.
That determinant is 4.
Here is a 2 by 2 determinant.
And that determinant is 40 minus
36, so happened to be 4 again.
So the determinant
of the matrix is 4.
But I also needed
the ones on the way.
I can't just find
the determinant
of the whole matrix.
That's the last
part of this test,
but I have to do all the
others as I get there.
So it passes that test.
Check.
It works.
So that test is passed.
I'm doing more work than I need
to do because one test would
have done the job.
Now here comes another one.
S is A transpose A. That's
what we looked at a minute ago.
If S has this form
A transpose A.
Oh, what did we
convince ourselves?
We said that this was
sure to be semidefinite.
And I needed some condition
to avoid A x equals 0.
There was the possibility
of A x equals 0.
I'll just bring that down.
You remember we started
there and ended up here.
And if A x was 0
then lambda was 0.
We were in the
semidefinite case.
So I have to avoid that.
So I have to say when A
has independent columns.
And I think I could factor that
matrix S into A transpose A.
I'm sure I could.
And get independent columns.
And it would pass test 4.
I want to go on to test 5.
Which really, in a way, is
the definition, the best
definition, of
positive definite.
So if I took number 5,
it's the energy definition.
So can I tell you
what that means?
I mean that x transpose Sx.
If I take my matrix S that I'm
testing for positive definite,
I multiply on the
right by any vector
x, any x, and on the
left by x transpose.
Well, I get a number.
S is a matrix.
Sx is a vector.
Inner product with a vector.
I get a number.
And that number should
be positive for all x.
Oh, I have to make
one exception.
If x is the 0 vector, then
of course that answer is 0.
All x except the 0 vector.
OK.
So that would be a
way to-- another test.
And this is associated in
applications with energy.
So I call this the
energy test, or really
the energy definition,
of positive definite.
x transpose Sx.
I'd like to apply that test.
So you'll see what does it mean.
Now we're looking at all x
to this particular example.
But I won't throw
away this board here.
You see eigenvalues, pivots,
determinants, A transpose A,
and energy.
Really all the pieces
of linear algebra.
A transpose A. We'll
see it more and more.
It comes up in least squares.
If I have a general matrix
A, it's not even square.
It doesn't have
great properties.
But when I compute
A transpose A,
then I get a symmetric matrix.
And now I know also a
positive semidefinite.
And with a little bit more
positive definite matrix.
OK.
By the way, are there five
tests for semidefinite matrices?
Yes.
There are five similar tests.
All eigenvalues
greater or equal to 0.
All pivots greater
or equal to 0.
I can go down this and just
allow that borderline case
that brings in semidefinite.
I won't do that.
Let me take my matrix S.
That small, example matrix.
And apply the energy test.
OK.
So I'm looking at energy.
So I'm looking at x.
That's x1 x2, times my matrix
4, 6, 6, 10, times x1 x2.
That's the energy.
That's my x transpose Sx.
x transpose Sx.
Is that what we
wanted to compute?
Yes.
x transpose Sx.
Now, can I compute that?
Yes.
It's a matrix multiplication.
Nothing magical here.
But when I do, I'll
show you the shortcut.
When I do that, a 4
x1 is going to appear,
and it'll be multiplied
by that x1 over there.
I'll get a 4 x1 squared.
And then I'll have a 6 x2
that's multiplying that x1.
So there's a 6 x1 x2.
And now from this.
That was the first component.
And now I have 6 x1 and 10 x2.
Multiply an x2.
Well, that's another 6 x1 x2.
And the 10, we'll
multiply x2 and x2.
x2 squared.
I did that quickly.
But the result is
just easy to see.
The 4, 6, 6, 10 show
up in the squares.
The diagonal 4 and 10
show up in the squares.
And the off diagonal
6, which doubles to 12,
shows up in the x1
x2, the cross term.
OK.
Now why should that-- so that's
a number for every x1 and x2.
Suppose x1 is 1 and x2 is 1.
Then the number I get is
4, plus 6, plus 6, plus 10.
That's probably 26.
It's positive.
What if x1 is 1--
let me try this.
x1 is 1 and x2 is minus 1.
Do I still get a
positive energy?
So my vector is 1 minus 1.
So I get 4.
Now, because of that, I
have minus 6, and minus 6,
and 10, from the x2 squared.
And that's 14 minus 12.
That's 2.
It's positive.
Well, I tested two vectors.
I tested the 1, 1 vector
and the 1, minus 1 vector.
But you have to know
that for every vector x,
this does turn out
to be positive.
And I can show you
that by something
called completing the square.
It's not what I plan to do.
But the beauty is we now
understand this energy test.
What it means to take x
transpose Sx, write it out,
and ask is it always positive.
Is it always positive?
OK.
So that's the fifth,
number 5, test.
But I think of it really
as the definition.
And it means-- can
I draw a picture?
Here is x1.
Here's x2.
And now I'm going to--
this is my function.
x transpose A x.
My energy.
If I graph that, I have an
x, and a y, and a function z.
That function of x and y.
What kind of a
graph does it have?
When x1 and x2
are 0, it's there.
When x1 and x2 move away
from 0, it goes positive.
That graph is like that.
It's sort of a bowl.
And I have a minimum.
One of the main application
of derivatives in calculus
is to find the
test for a minimum,
and decide minimum or maximum.
Minimum or maximum.
And you remember the
second derivative
decides a minimum or maximum.
Positive second
derivative, minimum.
Negative second
derivative, maximum.
It tells you about the
bending of the curve.
Well, we're in two
dimensions now,
with a function
of two variables.
This is multivariable calculus.
So what becomes positive
second derivative,
becomes positive
definite matrix.
A matrix of second derivatives.
This is the whole
subject of optimization.
Maximizing,
minimizing, comes here.
OK.
That's for another day.
I just would like
to tell you one more
thing about positive
definite matrices.
I got a book in the mail
which could be quite valuable.
It's a little
paperback, and the title
is Frequently Asked Questions in
Interviews for Financial Math.
Being a Quant.
Going to Wall Street.
Becoming rich.
So they don't give you
all the money right away.
They make you show that
you know something.
And so they ask a
few math questions.
And the first question was--
I was happy to see this.
The first question asked,
when is this matrix
positive definite?
OK.
Can you see that matrix?
1 is on the diagonal.
Those are correlation.
This is a correlation matrix.
That's why it's
important in finance.
It might be the
three correlations
of bonds, and stocks,
and foreign exchange.
So each one is
correlated to itself
with a full correlation of 1.
But there'll be a correlation
between bonds and stocks
going up together,
but not perfectly
together, by some number a.
And bonds and foreign
exchange with some number b.
Stocks and foreign
exchange, some number c.
So that's the matrix
of correlations.
And the key point is,
it is positive definite.
So the question when
you go to Wall Street
to apply for the money.
If you're asked what's the test
on those numbers a, b, c, to
have a positive definite,
proper correlation matrix?
I would suggest the
determinant test.
The determinant test, if
I'm given a small matrix,
I'll just do the determinants.
So that determinant is 1.
No problem.
This determinant, what's
the 2 by 2 determinant?
1 minus a squared.
So 1 minus a squared
has to be positive.
I'm doing the determinant test.
And what's the 3
by 3 determinant?
1 from the diagonal.
And I have an acb and an acb.
I think I have two acb's
from the three terms.
Now, those terms
have the plus signs.
And now I have some
with a minus sign,
which better not be too big.
That's the whole point on
positive definite matrices.
The off diagonal is not allowed
to overrun the diagonal.
The diagonal should be
the biggest numbers.
OK.
So I saw that a squared
had to be below 1.
But now what's the
determinant test?
I think this has to
be bigger than what
I'm getting from
this direction, which
is a b squared, and a c
squared, and an a squared.
Oh, look at that.
a squared, b squared,
and c squared.
That would be the answer.
That first test there.
Second test there.
Well, the easy test was
just 1, is positive.
So really, that's what
they're looking for.
That would be the
test, those numbers.
So abc can't be too large
or that would begin to fail.
Good.
So positive definite matrices
have lots of applications.
Here was minimum.
Here was correlation
matrices and finance.
Many, many other places.
Let me just bring
down the five tests.
Eigenvalues, pivots,
determinants, A transpose A,
and energy.
And I'll stop there.
Thank you.